hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on monster on a roll again
today we're gonna be doing another solo
guy but it's gonna be a little bit
different than from the regular monster
we're gonna be talking about the HR 29
quest you'll unlock after you beat the
campaign so let's get started
the quest is gonna be called beyond the
blasting scales and like I said it
unlocks an HR 29 if you beat the game
you get HR 13 then you have to grind all
the way up to HR 29 and cannot continue
after 2 H star 30 until after you beat
this quest the quest as you fight to
tempered bezel cases or bagel goose or
b-52 bomber or whatever the hell you
want to call him but for the people who
don't know what tempered means that
monster basically means it deals more
damage they don't have more health they
only deal more damage also since there's
two monsters it means their health is
slightly lowered because there's more
than one of them
so to recap if anybody was confused this
fight is gonna have you fight to basal
geeses with more damage and slightly
less health now that that is out of the
way let's read up on his sociology
report and see what he's week two also I
want to point out before we get into the
report I probably butchered his name so
I do apologize for that I've been doing
that a lot with all these monsters
they're very hard for me to say but
either way according to the report his
head wings and Tails are gonna be his
weak points with his head winged tail
and body being breakable and or
severable if you use a melee weapon
definitely want to aim for the head and
if you have a ranged weapon you can
either aim for the head or wings doesn't
matter for his weaknesses he is most
weak to thunder with ice and dragon
being the second best option and for
elements everything is basically average
except blast and it's done so I
basically want to stick with thunder for
this fight but the recommended gear
you'll want to bring the obvious mega
potions and vitality mantle and I also
recommend some flash pods but we'll get
into that a little bit later I'm also
unsure if the fireproof Manta will work
but because bezel geese does have a few
fire attacks bro I recorded the fight I
didn't use the fireproof mantle but it
probably wouldn't hurt to have now the
not what we're going to do is talk and
learn his moves and then talk about the
areas then a few tips at the end so
let's get started with that
so first up to get this out of the way
bezel geese will have two forms one
normal form and one where his body is
covered in red and orange basically to
signify a fire form in his fire form the
exits hanging from his chin and tail
will frequently drop and explode so
definitely be careful in this form
because that will catch you off guard
also another huge problem that occurs in
this fight is that most of the time both
of them will come during the fight
highly
recommend letting it them fight each
other when two of them are in the same
exact areas you so you don't get caught
in the crossfire cuz their attacks do
hurt especially because they're tempered
eventually after taking enough damage
one of them will leave leaving you to
focus on only one of them instead of
having to fight both at the same time
but for the moves the first move is this
head rush attack where he slams his head
on the ground and then pushes forward
trying to knock you over running a
rolling away will completely evade this
move no problem
next move is this dive-bomb move where
what he does he flies and drops his egg
sacks on the ground for a few stripes
then dives bomb right dive bombs right
through them making them explode you can
easily run away from the direction of
these eggs hats and siga off to the side
if you're caught in the area then end up
sprint drumming in and when to get all
this damage if you don't know how to
sprint yup all you have to do is sheath
your weapons that you're running just
with your hands and then press the jump
button and your guys should jump in the
air flow his arms and he should land
smack on his stomach on the floor it has
incredible invincibility frames and you
should dodge the entire attack without
taking any damage another move is this
fire blast attack he will step back a
bit and then blast a fireball at you
simply rolling at the right time will be
fine and also since this is a fire
attack I'm not entirely sure as to fire
fire proof man so will work here but I
believe it should negate some damage if
you're hit by it he also has a tail
smash move this will only happen if
you're behind him you can easily dodge
his move since pretty obvious when he's
going to slam when his tail is lifted in
the air another move is similar to the
head rush but what he will do is he will
drop some egg sacks on the floor and
slam them causing them to explode all
while slightly rushing forward to
headbutt you you can easily run away or
dodge roll you definitely don't want to
be caught under him when this happens so
definitely be careful with that because
the egg sets probably do more damage
than just his head rushing you so you're
gonna be taking lots of hits with this
and you're also gonna be caught on fire
so definitely be aware if you're
underneath him
for the areas there wasn't really much
in the first area there was a huge rock
in the first one which could potentially
ko him if he runs into it in the next
area there is a few rocks similar to
that which when destroyed could be used
for a spot for mounting and a slug for
sliding attacks if you want to use those
as well and then one of the last areas
that I fought him in which was in his
nest
you can jump down to an area on the side
for some quick healing of being attacked
there wasn't really us mulch much in
these areas that I found that was
helpful now to end this I have a few
quick tips on this Basile goose fight
basically his eggs
sex work similar to new Gurgaon taste
spikes when they regenerate he will do a
big attack once they're full to fully
deplete them this move being the
dive-bombing one we talked about earlier
his egg sacs will also randomly drop one
full and when in fire mode will call
some exploiting fire damage and defect
that by the fire damage simply roll
three times to extinguish it if you're
stuck finding both of them at the same
time then let them fight it out and
dodge if one of their attacks is going
to hit you and only attack if you know
you're going to get guaranteed damage
you will have to move very quickly with
this because you might get hit by the
other one also trying to fight you next
tip is that flash pods also do work on
him you want to save those for when he's
in the air doing the dive-bomb move so
he can stay on the ground longer and you
can get more guaranteed damage because
you want to get as much damage as
possible wall he can't hit you and also
just remember that in fire mode each
move does have the potential to knock
off some of his egg sacs on the floor
making them explode so if you're ever
fighting him in fire mode just be aware
that one of those sacks might fall from
his chin or his tail and they might hit
you so always be on the lookout for that
if you found some things I missed like
moves that I didn't mention or rocks
that happen to be hanging on the ceiling
that I didn't catch in some of the areas
or any other tips he used to fight this
boss or this quest let everyone know in
the comments below so that everyone can
be fully informed on this fight and
that's all I have for you guys today
like the video if you guys did enjoy it
really does help me out subscribe if
you're new it cover a lot of Monster
Hunter wolf content such as solo guides
other types of guides I'm gonna be doing
lots of builds for the dual blades
guides on the dual blades and then just
builds in general things that I'm coming
up with that I might think are pretty
enjoyable or to be too please put in a
video but with that guys my two most
recent monster videos are going to be on
screen if you guys do want to check
those out definitely go check those out
if you want and with that guys hope you
have a great rest of your day and peace
out